and going through another member's bit about questions and we have some
lots of right freelancers and so forth.
Yeah, so recently we've had some questions come in regarding perspective
patients and current patients who have been informed by other people that using
the right machine while doing the chemotherapy is back that the right machine
actually has a negative impact on patients who are doing the chemotherapy in this
contract indicated. So I wanted to kind of assess out some of my thoughts on this.
Yeah, I thought those comments was the silly, honestly, probably for somebody who
doesn't really understand what the right machines do to the body and how they
help with kids. So remember, right, believe that there was a
horrible, possibly frequency residents of a cell. And if you get a cell or
an organism with this, with their own frequency, cause the cell to
lice or the organisms membrane to lice and it would die.
So that was his theory though and it's been shown with that.
That's not obviously the case with kids or so, using the right machine isn't
that they could think of if the cancer cells died and they're going to be cancer-free.
However, when you do get anything, including the cell, including the cancer
cell, it's a frequency you can cause in a primary. But that's going to cause
a recognition by a immune system to that cell and that's one theory.
And in other theories, if you're using nutritional,
nutraceutical cancer killers, when I'm saying, Hawksy, your proto-cell,
or use it a venousinal cancer killer, like chemotherapy,
the cancer cell may uptake that nutritional or
venousinal product more effectively and they would actually help
chemotherapy for the case of a company in therapy target the cancer cell better.
So if you're stimulating that cell, in this case cancer cell,
with its own frequency, you can help the chemotherapy target the cancer cell better.
And it's the same dog with using nutraceuticals, if you're taking nutraceuticals to help kill
the cancer, using the right, along with the nutraceuticals that help the cancer cell,
help the nutraceutical target the cancer cell, so it can create a fact of the cancer cell for effectively.
So I just can't understand what mechanism of action, of course,
would be thinking that there would be a collaterated vacation with right therapy
with the people there if you're anything else, if you use this thing in the service.
With the same thought you drew, if somebody was also doing nutraceuticals
that there's a possibility that you're using the right machine,
it's going to be kind of a fishhole for the rehabilitation to do its work, or is it a different function?
No, it's the exact same mechanism as the big one.
So there are certain things you've dealt with a lot to do if you're doing nutraceuticals.
There are things, so if you're doing nutraceuticals, there are things that are highly oxidative.
And so is radiation, that's how it kills things.
It's oxidizing, it needs to just like any chemical poison that you would take in.
If you took in an excessive amount of arsenic, you would die because it's an oxidizing
condition because it's cell that, well that's what nutraceuticals therapy does as well.
So do you know what to use anti-oxidants?
What you're doing people there, so let's say I choose to do people therapy
that I don't want to take anti-oxidants like alpha-bac acid, vitamin C,
while I'm doing people therapy because I would be in a sense protecting the cells and
negating the effect of the people therapy, but that's not what the right does.
So they're not understanding all the theories of mechanisms of action with the right,
the right but not happy as anti-oxidant, so it's not that beneficial,
so really there's a good, any counter-indications in my book with the right,
but if someone is doing their treatment therapy, it's highly beneficial.
Well this will be incredibly beneficial for many of our patients,
which is both an alternative approach and then have chosen to do people therapy or
radiation, that this can hopefully be something that's a greater benefit to them
on that protecting them necessarily from it, but also helping them to utilize those
traditional therapies to their maximum.
So you're going to do people therapy, we want it to work on it, so anything that we could do
from an integrated perspective to help that people target that care for
their cells, it's going to be fully effective.
Thank you very much.